foreign
you would hope that the Silver Lining
around our mortality one of the benefits
of dying is that at least you're finally
spared from our incredibly woke and
tremendously stupid culture but the
problem is that our culture is so
incredibly woke and so tremendously
stupid that you can't even fully Escape
it in Death long after you've died your
body decomposed into the ground the the
woke Brigade might still come along and
cancel you now granted when you're dead
you probably won't care very much things
will either be going so well for you at
that point or so poorly that it's not
going to bother you much either way to
find out that you've caused an extremely
belated controversy on Twitter but those
of us who are still alive will have to
deal with it so even if you aren't
troubled
it's annoying as hell for the rest of us
and that brings us to Judy Garland who
is the latest dead person to find
themselves on the cancellation Chopping
Block Garland died over 50 years ago
that didn't stop her from provoking Mass
outrage on multiple social social media
platforms over the weekend when the woke
Brigade found out that Judy Garland in
the 1930s almost 100 years ago did
blackface
now one of the posts calling attention
to this fact came from some random
Twitter account that published an image
of the actress in blackface along with
this caption quote two movies a year
apart same
shout out to gen Z for teaching me this
now that post was viewed 57 million
times
tick-tockers also got in on the action
here's another random account that
managed to uh get a lot of traction with
a post calling attention to the
blackface issue watch we talk about Judy
Garland as a child in blackface
I'm in Florida Carry Me
to hold
oh I come from the south
from way down south
where the cone and potatoes used to go
dance great big elegant pictures show
and My Old Kentucky Home is a friend
Chateau way down south indexes
[Music]
I think we got something there
all right so that's real music at least
now from there the media jumped into
action Outlets like Newsweek and the
Daily Dot published articles on the
subject the rap had this headline Judy
Garland criticized for wearing blackface
in 1938 white people found this an
acceptable form of entertainment
yes those dastardly white people it's
important that we spend all of our time
looking for all the bad things white
people did in history we must leave no
stone unturned
did anyone of any other race enjoy forms
of entertainment in 1938 that we today
would find offensive
well who cares that's not important all
that matters is what white people were
doing wrong and here's another thing
that they were doing wrong
of course if you really want to be upset
about white people and blackface you
don't have to go back that far I mean
there's always Justin Trudeau or Jimmy
Kimmel
but Trudeau was a leftist and Kimmel
voted for Biden so they get off the hook
now Garland probably also voted for
Biden since she's dead but that did not
absolve her apparently
now we should note that some people did
come to Judy Garland's defense they
swept in to add nuance and contextualize
the Judy Garland blackface Scandal and
although these Nuance adders are less
crazy and slightly less obnoxious than
the woke mob they still missed the point
by several thousand miles uh watch this
Judy Garland was trending yesterday on
the app formerly known as Twitter let's
discuss this user expressed their
outrage at finding out that Judy Garland
had made films with blackface if you
don't know me hi my name is Tori I'm a
Wizard of Oz historian and collector and
as such I know a lot about Judy Garland
her filmography and her career before we
begin I want to start by giving a
trigger warning because I will be
showing images and some clips from films
that have blackface scenes but I hope
even if you are made uncomfortable by
this type of content you will try to
muddle through because it's important to
talk about I'd also like to add the
caveat that I'm coming at this from the
perspective of a white person and
therefore my voice in this conversation
is not as important as black voices
well if you're hoping for a rational
Common Sense perspective you've already
heard three things here that should
temper those expectations specifically
there's her caveat that her voice
doesn't matter because she's white also
she unironically offers trigger warnings
and perhaps most concerning of all she
identifies herself as a Wizard of Oz
historian which sounds a bit like
claiming that you're an anthropologist
who specializes in studying the ancient
Kingdom of wakanda
we're not starting on the right foot
here to put a mildly but let's keep
listening anyway here it is
I'm not going to sit here and make
apologies for blackface or to try to
justify it it's gross it's gross but
here's the truth about Judy Garland's
participation in this she had no agency
over what roles she did here's Judy
Garland signing her MGM contract at the
age of 13. in which she also agreed to
give her mother Ethel gum a portion of
her weekly paycheck making her the main
Breadwinner for her entire family Louis
B Mayer was not shy about making sure
that his Stars stuck to their contracts
Judy Garland was assigned scripts to do
and then she did them two movies a year
apart same because it's much easier to
just blame Judy Garland rather than the
patriarchal system that made her
decisions for her
and there it is let's not cancel Judy
Garland from the year 1938 let's instead
cancel the patriarchy from the Year
1938. this is what we get from Garland's
Defenders
though she does make one correct point
which has been echoed by nearly everyone
else defending Judy Garland from this
posthumous cancellation attempt it's
true that she was a kid when she
performed in blackface she didn't have
full agency over her decisions all of
that is true
but it's also not really the reason why
it's so stupid to get offended by a
blackface performance from the 1930s the
real reason is simply that performing in
blackface in the 1930s was not some
great sin back then it doesn't matter
how old she was at the time what matters
is the time the 1930s that's the only
relevant detail here that's all that
needs to be said
in a world filled with uncertainties one
shocking headline can spread panic like
wildfire and grocery stores are empty
within hours it's crucial then to be
ready for whatever comes your way having
reliable food storage system can provide
you with peace of mind and the assurance
that you and your loved ones will be
well taken care of right now with my
Patriot Supply you'll save 200 on a
three-month emergency food kit to help
stock your supply go to prepare with
walsh.com and grab the special price
before it ends your three-month
emergency food kit provider provides
over 2 000 calories each day for optimal
strength and energy in stressful
situations you can enjoy a wide variety
of my Patriot Supply food from
buttermilk pancakes and chicken alfredo
to rice pudding their meals have have
you covered for every part of your day
the best part is that each meal is
delicious it's better to have an
emergency food supply and not need it
than to knead it and not have it don't
wait for disaster to strike before
taking action invest in your safety and
well-being by securing your food storage
today go to prepare with walsh.com and
get 200 in savings with each kit your
family needs that's prepare with
walsh.com
blackface was not a big deal in the
1930s now we might consider it a big
deal today unless you're the Canadian
Prime Minister but the people living in
the 1930s were living in the 1930s not
in the Modern Age
okay they just didn't see it that way
you could say well they should have seen
it that way yeah but they didn't okay so
they just didn't that's all
judging them by modern standards it's
not just unfair and wrong though it is
both of those things it's also
incoherent it doesn't make sense you
might as well say that Johnny Unitas
wasn't a good quarterback because he
never scored any home runs just you're
judging by a completely different set of
Standards it doesn't mean anything
see I will never stop marveling at the
fact
that we live in a society filled with
moral relativists who are relativistic
about about everything
except the one thing they should be you
know in a certain sense relativistic
about
most of the time these people can be
heard saying things like hey I'm just
living my truth man hey don't impose
your morality on me
normally they would say that truth and
morality are fundamentally and
substantively relative that that they
change entirely from person to person
And yet when it comes to assessing the
actions of our ancestors of people who
lived decades and centuries ago
these very same people suddenly become
merciless and stringent moralists
imposing One Way unwavering set of
morals on people who don't agree with it
now the irony of course is that
this one time when they dropped the
relativistic gig is the one time when it
would actually apply again in a certain
sense
and let me explain what that sense is
moral truth does not change over time
what is objectively immoral today was
object objectively immoral 90 years ago
and 900 years ago so moral truth is not
relative
however moral culpability is relative
okay you don't need to factor in the
century and decade when a sin occurred
in order to decide if it was a sin but
you do need to factor those things in if
you're trying to assign moral
responsibility for those sins
and if you're trying to assess the
degree of moral responsibility
a wrong action does not become more or
less wrong over time but an individual
can be more or less responsible for that
wrong action over time
which means that the amount of personal
responsibility that we should assign to
individuals for racial insensitivity in
the 1930s or any time period before that
is basically nothing
okay there's a essentially no
responsibility racial sensitivity as we
recognize it today
did not exist in the world anywhere
among any group of people a century ago
how much blame should we give to any one
individual for not having personally
achieved a racial Enlightenment that
nobody else in the world had achieved
either
how much guilt should we assess to
people who fail to have developed the
kind of racial sensitivities that nobody
else on the globe during that era had
developed either
the answer to those questions is
basically none
and this is the fact you have to deal
with
people in history saw the world
differently they saw each other
differently
uh they therefore acted very differently
and that's just the way it was
you could be mad about it
you could be upset
it can make your tummy hurt
but your anger is futile and stupid
and mostly it is a cover it is an excuse
now I'll back up it's not yeah you're
stupid but you're also a coward
okay it's cowardice as well
because you want to spend your time
blaming other people for their lack of
moral Insight while not thinking at all
about your own inadequacies in that
regard
Judy Garland didn't see a problem with
blackface because uh really nobody at
that time saw a problem with it
and you can waste time canceling Judy
Garland for that or you can ask yourself
what evils do you support and promote
today just because everyone else
supports and promotes it
where are your moral blind spots
maybe stop and think about that
before you go searching for another dead
person to lecture for their shortcomings
and that is why those who are trying to
cancel Judy Garland are themselves today
certainly canceled hey YouTube thanks
for listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there